last time i was here
i was showing how
you do this
and don't cut down
watch you know don't take my word for it
watch youtube different teachers it
doesn't matter who you watch
a lot of teachers i'll do this and
they'll cut that one down and they'll
push in there
you will not see psycho centre do that
but you ask a question you ask a
question mentally so because you're
seeing this album go down they're saying
this can't go down but that's because
he's falling down
so of course he's going to get down but
there's a difference if you watch the
teachers so there's a difference between
watching that
and watching
the hand following the person down and
so this is where you should uh you know
this see i'm holding him up the same
technique as kite
i've got control of him he hasn't
controlled himself he just thinks yes
so you
know
so
you do this you spin them all right it's
like a tammy but to send a wave through
his body
so you go one and you go like that you
don't cut it down
i choose that direction or that
direction so i go here i'm going to
choose that direction
i'm not going to choose
that direction
if i choose a cut down
see now i haven't got him he's decided i
think i can reset with you resist
sensing here so i'm going to go for that
who do you think you are
making me look bad
a lot of senses don't like being made to
look before because
it does stop them they think
hmm i think i stopped sensitive
i had that problem
my teachers stopped using me after a
while
because they're likely that didn't work
cited says if he goes
you know off of this
turn them
my knee goes out
my direction goes there and then i
follow them down as they fall i follow
them i follow them so i have control i
step in
so this is basic
this is basic copy dozer
there's another one where they push on
the knees
they push on their knees
a lot of people again sadly are strong
people
we take the knee like that and we take
it right over there
and this arm instead of falling down
where where it was on the knee instead
of falling down there
we tend to they'll tend to move it
danny's good because he's not letting me
try to show you it wrong
so he's not letting me take over a lot
of people do that because it it helps me
get this next bit of the technique
so
if i cheat if i cheat
and do that then he's already leaning so
with this hand on here i can
do the technique
because to do the technique correctly is
too difficult
because when i take my knee away
i have to turn over
my hand
if i don't
then he's still on top of my hand
so now i'm not going to get this hand
over there
so what i do is i take my knee away
i spin that hand that pins his fingers
that's broken his balance
this hand then has got nothing to stop
it and what i do is i roll that
there
that lets me take this hand out really
easily
this is a beautiful technique we won't
be doing this saturday because there
won't be no nuts
one
two
three
it looks easy it's very difficult to do
without using strength because we've all
got straight don't know who we are so we
don't know when we're using it
but this is the thing not used